is line down the center okay left foot's
going to be on the left side of the line
right foot's going to be on the right
side of the line show
me yes and then that right foot on the
right side of the line a little further
out this way yes so you see how that
line is always in the center yeah for
now it's going to be your center of
balance so you're going to slightly sit
okay keep your arms right by your
eyebrows so you're here though look at
my hands keep the elbow in and now
you're facing me so think about it like
a like you have a coffee mug you're
pouring it out okay pour it
out yes and come back sit again there
you go like that so it's kind of like a
snap yes so twist and then throw it same
thing with the coffee mug pour it out
yes
again good five more one two three now
three four five